what has become of this city there used
to be does justice not anymore
crime is out of control cats are missing
and townspeople are being victimized we
were supposed to protect those who
couldn't protect themselves get off my
car you [ __ ]
now superheroes are torn apart by
political differences we are two sides
at war
[Music]
but Lord isn't going to save our city
time Travis my only hope now midst out
of ancient times when a new king United
a kingdom torn apart by a powerful sting
there's no time to waste
I have to go back change the present if
I can and in doing so perhaps I can
change what has happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we should be happy that he's made
friends in this town so quickly we came
here to hide more friends just means
more trouble you're being paranoid
you need to lay off that stuff it's
changing you oh it's the one thing that
helps me relax from your stupid [ __ ] oh
hey whippersnapper didn't see you there
your friends are downstairs kiddo get
out there and play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you just move to town and you get
to be king I think you're a little [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm not afraid of you and your strategic
King fellows
[Music]
we can't stop him
ready the dark of the dark part
[Music]
can't take us all on yet wait
oh it's fine
you can't keep the Moors down
your butt needs [ __ ] making but you
can still punch up
that was super gross but not gross
enough to defeat beatable
you have no chance against all of us
let's go reset even sidecar Macau
stand aside aside we're going through
that door you can't oh yeah why not
because everything and voting here is
lava is lava
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't shrug off your Feeny blowing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
rats
[Music]
go get your church way it's gonna hit
you
[Applause]
okay barking gets his hammer at Lorain
[Music]
stay on the street
damn kids clear
[Music]
oh my god he defeated the dragon don't
freaking way
that kids amazing there's a way in
through the garage
[Music]
[Music]
I got the king was going to do a sweet
jump and then he just did that speak
Bard
what happened to the stick of truth the
wizard had it thrown into the ocean lies
you shall feel the wrath of the Morris
unhand him you heathens release the
Bartle you'll have the King to do it the
King they say he can slay a dragon with
one blow that's right if you don't wait
where is it
I thought he was with you guys now we
got a distress they know to come help
him gear wizard in town my name is the
kid I'm from the future we said we're
not playing God anymore
yeah we're all split up what's the point
this is the voice in mad time there is a
massive crime wave and missing cats
I knew my only hope was to assemble the
team hey you can't switch games like
that where's the stick of truth shut up
Kevin isn't about some dumb stick
there's a cat in trouble and it's the
key to finding the crime syndicate new
to our town in the future
that sounds too heavy for Putin well
what do you want glad you want a [ __ ]
freedom pal to find the missing cat get
the hundred dollar reward I made their
superhero franchise more popular suck
secrete account - that's right
oops again coming from your basement
playroom [ __ ] friends go get your stuff
and report back to the cooler the future
pudding friends this bimbo sorry guys
you can't play with us we're playing
superheroes now and you guys are dorks
why to go play Star Trek I'd Spock
oh hello the boys are down in their
little basement playroom Eric's spending
so much time playing superheroes I'm
afraid he's not eating [ __ ] you oh did
you get locked out
I'm afraid little Eric put a lock on the
door to keep me out I'm sure he has the
passcode written down here somewhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes officer
somebody appears to have put lova in
front of my door what no it's not hard
but my son told me I will burn to death
if I try and cross it uh-huh
oh yes he did tell me that if I step on
a crack it would break my mother's back
it won't [ __ ] you mom know anything
that's not enough mosquito we have to
act fast before the freedom pals can
$100 reward do you know what that could
mean to our superhero franchise that cat
looks pretty old maybe just died in the
gutter somewhere human I have to remind
you that as of right now freedom pals
have a hundred followers on Instagram we
have six the five of us and Billy Turner
who's a ginger this is the key to
finally beating those [ __ ] but where
do we start looking that cat could be
anyway we need to split up
mosquito take to the air and check out
all the city parks you got it but steal
away human cash see if the cat is stuck
up a tree somewhere you've got the storm
drain super Craig
that's pass I need you to use your
superhuman speed to get to the mayor's
office and tell her we're on the case
don't worry [ __ ] you can count on me to
get there
keep it
give me
supa Craig super Craig this is cute do
you copy
super Craig the [ __ ] are you I repeat
duck [ __ ] are you super Craig oh wait
now the security system isn't working
dude what the [ __ ]
ordinary citizens aren't allowed in the
Koon there we're playing superheroes now
and you aren't a superhero new kids so
[ __ ] off okay alright look you can watch
us play superheroes as long as you don't
get in the way make yourself useful go
grab me this the furnace ii device it's
over there
[Music]
you seriously can't find the Serenity
device a superhero's use inspection well
that took long enough
the first e device active you really
want to be a superhero have play with
the big boys well maybe maybe you can be
useful have a seat at the table
douchebag
let's see mosquitoes AVL's Jesus Christ
are these even in a human language
alright in order to play superheroes you
have to have a superhero persona then
you can fill out your character sheet on
Kunta Graham do you have a crystal gram
page huh boy you're not even on cue
Instagram huh well I guess I can create
one for you so the first thing we need
to fill out on your character sheet is
your class you know what kind of
superhero are you since you're a newbie
you can only choose between three for
now but that's just black with rage
power and like Cyclops ok douchebag but
now we need to find out what terrible
thing in your past drives you dizzy
douche all superheroes have a compelling
backstory it's from that backstory that
their powers gain meaning let's take you
back to when you were just a child you
lay awake that night like so many other
nights you couldn't sleep because you
knew you weren't like the other kids you
walked to the mirror you walked to the
mirror over there the mirror
just okay just walk up no not there
nothing damn it you looked in the mirror
and you felt alone and that's when it
happened a loud noise you swore you
could hear your mother calling for help
you left your room out in the hallway
you saw two intruders in front of your
parents door you had to stop them from
hurting your parents you knew you had
the power to stop them so for the first
time you called upon your pastor Howard
[Music]
as a blazing blaster hero you began to
overheat as a fire in your belly and
edit you wasted no time delivering six
burns into the balance before you names
cleared the intruders realize what they
are up against then your mom tell you
not to play with fire the intruders
moved into attacks
you've left us no choice kid
the enemy's closing in you gave yourself
some space fine knocking your folks back
but the intruders wouldn't take getting
pushed around like you you can't push us
around like that
[Music]
little did they know they set themselves
up for destruction
[Music]
I'll just get out of the way his comrade
falling the extras they went those days
not so hot now your little flavor shall
we show him you were gravely injured but
the intruders blows only awaken the fire
fraternity
you swallowed the pain and unleash your
ultimate attack
and so you beat them all seem to be okay
but then you finally reached your
parents door and what you saw when you
open that door changed your life forever
and led you to fighting crime too late
because when you open that door you saw
you saw your dad [ __ ] your man that's a
pretty heavy backstory you fight crime
because you never forgot the night you
weren't in time and you saw your own
father the man you trusted [ __ ] your
mind it's like a ripple in time you
can't ever change isn't it alright
alright now that you're a superhero I
have a mission for you I need you to go
out into town and try to get as many
followers as you can on Coetzee gram
it's the only way our franchise was
[Music]
why didn't you keep in my space I'm busy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's Sophie yes I've heard of those
oh isn't this fun
[Music]
Oh wonderful I'll see you on the
Internet
[Music]
you'll need more followers before I
selfie with you
UK looks like you've reached the edge of
our known universe beyond there lies the
limits of time and space
I'll selfie with you would you have more
followers okay
sorry I don't follow just anyone on
social media
can you help me with this thing it's
stuck
hey you got it open you're the real deal
little superhero a selfie sure kid let's
do it
[Music]
okay nice okay I guess you're popular
enough to selfie with
hey can we take the shot we're friends
now I guess you just go the other way
the twin thing
[Music]
now I guess we have enough Mutual's it
we can selfie you're gaining followers
pretty fast keep up the good work
I'm still having trouble reaching some
of the kyun friends you might want to
see what's going on
cat-boy
those are sixth-graders they're the most
vile evil beings known to superheroes
you guys are stupid everyone knows
Kieffer's mom has the nicest boobs dude
shut up about my mom's beards bro why
don't you make me sit face you guys want
to go to the movies there might be some
boobs in wonder women movies are dumb
let's go shoot some hoops basketball
stupid bro hey I know when I finish
kicking your butt I'm gonna kick your
stupid frog foot
[Music]
[Music]
no Bercy new kid the bully has become
the bully I'm still the bullied
shut up 4440 scum you guys are kind of
scrappy wow you really beat up you saved
me
[Music]
Wow nice work new kid you took down a
sixth grader
[Music]
[Music]